Die absolute sensation zum ersten mal ist ein
Interstellare objekt durch unser sonnensystem gerast zumindest ist es das erste derartige objekte dass wir gesichtet haben und es ist extrem
seltsam seine form und sein verhalten sind absolut rätselhaft die neuesten erkenntnisse über das geheimnisvolle
interstellare objekt jetzt endlich zum science fiction herzlich willkommen
Am zweiten september 2017 tauchte das interstellare objekt senkrecht zu den umlaufbahnen der planeten in unserem sonnensystem
zwischen sonne und merkur bahn ein
Die gravitation der sondern lenkte das objekt dann
Unterhalb der sonne in richtung erde um wo es unterhalb der erdumlaufbahn
Am 14 oktober an der erde vorbei flog inzwischen ist das objekt durch die umlenkung der sonne wieder über die planeten hinaus geschossen worden
Dabei wurde das objekt erst entdeckt als es schon an der erde vorbeigeflogen war am 18 oktober
2017 störte das
1,8
meter teleskop an stars 1 auf der hawaii-insel maui das objekt auf und dann ergaben die bahn berechnung
Des objektes sehr schnell dass es nicht von dieser. Welt war nicht von einem anderen planeten
Im sonnensystem und überhaupt nicht aus unserem sonnensystem es gab noch überhaupt
keine kategorie für das objekt und weil es irrtümlich für einen asteroiden gehalten wurde bekam das erste mal die falsche bezeichnung a
2017 u1 ich hatte ja, im ersten video über das objekt gefragt wie ihr die kategorie benennen wollt eure vorschläge waren zum beispiel
kino oder
fom
Jetzt hat die internationale astronomische union eine neue kategorie für das interstellare objekt eingeführt
Ist jetzt die bezeichnung danke für eure vorschläge es ist jetzt also 1 2000 17 uhr 1 und hat auch schon einen hawaiianischen
namen bekommen
Januar in der hawaiianische sprache spiegelt dies dieser name die art und weise wieder in der dieses objekt wie ein
Kundschafter unter boote ist der aus der fernen vergangenheit geschickt wurde um uns zu erreichen
Heißt es in einer studie der universität hawaii die sich mit diesem ersten
Interstellaren objekt beschäftigt und was jetzt absolut verblüfft auch seine eigenschaften sind ganz anders als die von asteroiden aus unserem sonnensystem
das interstellare objekt hat eine extrem seltsame form eher die eines spiels oder eines raumschiffes zitat
Dieses ding ist sehr merkwürdig das sagt karl match von der universität hawaii das team der forscherin hat das objekt jetzt aufgrund von
Beobachtungstag näher beschrieben und es ist wirklich total merkwürdig mit dem very large telescope der europäischen südsternwarte
eso in den chilenischen anden wurde herausgefunden dass das objekt alle 73 stunden
Um seine eigene achse rotiert und dabei immer heller und wieder dunkler wird um das zehnfache
diese
ungewöhnlich starke helligkeits änderung deutet darauf hin dass das objekt sehr lang gezogen sein muss etwa zehnmal so lang wie breit
mit einer komplexen gebundenen form
Erklärt die forscherin mit auch extrem seltsam das objekt hat eine farbe es ist rot das ist
wirklich wirklich alles extrem seltsam da gastein interstellare objekt durch unser sonnensystem
Und es ist so anders wie alles was wir kennen wenn es nicht so unglaublich unwahrscheinlich wäre könnte man es für ein raumschiff halten
So extrem seltsam wie es aussieht hinzu kommt außerdem konnten wir bestätigen das ist
vollständig inaktiv ist weil wir in seiner direkten umgebung nicht den geringsten hinweis auf staub finden konnten
Berichtet mieters ist echt merkwürdig und das forschungsteam vermutet dass das fremde objekt aus gestein oder einen mix mit hohen metallanteil besteht
Und anders als zunächst vermutet hat es nicht einen durchmesser von 160 meter sondern war sogar
400 meter lang es ist ein wirklich wirklich seltsames objekt was meint ihr dass es, wahr
Wenn ihr kein video zum thema und auch zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann wird mir hier ein aber aufs auge und vergessen nicht
Den auf die glocke der nur dann verpasst er kein video hier geht es weiter also hier und da für einfach draufklicken mit
sensation interstellare objekt rast durchs sonnensystem mit weiteren infos zur entdeckung des rätselhaften objekt zu ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran